dans une poudrière pleine à craquer le
légendaire groupe pousse à nous ça va
mais l'ambiance dès les premières
chansons le public est compris
[Musique]
ça nous ça va c'est la base en fait
c'est la base c'est le seum super
vraiment super toujours le top le top la
Réunion Bata elle est magnifique c'est
le feu ça c'est la Réunion vraiment
[Musique]
avec plus de 40000 personnes sur trois
jours de festival le sac il faut 2023 a
battu tous les records la prestation de
Louise Attaque sur la scène de salahin
et gravé dans les mémoires le groupe
français a mis le feu les plus grands
tubes ont été repris par près de 15000
fans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
genre c'est pas forcément nos
années mais ça mélange toute
la génération et l'ambiance festoche
c'est génial ça se danse à toute époque
c'est top
moi j'aime quand même il faut absolument
qu'il revienne parce que là qu'on
connaît un concert encore plus long je
veux que ça déchire on va jouer et on va
danser ensemble on y va jusqu'à minuit
passé la fête a pu durer pour le plus
grand plaisir des festivaliers l'as
comme tant d'autres artistes avant lui a
fait bouger la jauge des filous
[Musique]
un peu plus tôt le groupe madiacanu et
c'est percussions africaines avaient
fait bouger le public
la salle verte a aussi offert quelques
bons moments durant ce festival Simon
gavol a clôturé la scène sur le rythme
maloya tout un symbole clap de fin sur
le sac il faut 2023 qui a encore une
fois démontré que la musique réchauffe
les cœurs
[Musique]